like i'm like vetting out more of the
spiritual side of things
and um you know theorizing that there
was an original energy in the universe
the sophia energy
and that it comes down and and and it
fractions off so it can know itself and
so if we look at it from that spiritual
perspective
i feel like that also could make sense
too trying to experience itself
information and informing us are
our we i've been thinking about this a
lot how being a human is actually fairly
simple and that
everything in our reality is really
giving us information about ourself
whether it's through triggers or
projections or how someone treats you
it's all information about the self and
so that could be
that spirit that source energy god
whatever you want to call it
sophia energy original energy
experiencing itself
learning about itself so what are your
thoughts on
it being more from a spiritual
perspective yeah you know i think the
line between
uh spirituality and science and everyday
life gets really fuzzy
when when we begin where do you well
honestly where do you draw the line
between everyday life and spirituality
where do you draw the line between light
and dark
in the moment i'll just tell you the
moment you draw that line you've fallen
into the ancient
trap that keeps us stuck and spinning
in the false boundaries that we
in the past have locked ourselves into i
have friends in the spiritual community
that say i only hang out with
people of the light i only hang out with
spiritual people
and i say you know that's cool where do
you draw the line
between the people that are spiritual
and the ones that are not in the moment
you do that you're in judgment
and that judgment is what keeps you
locked into your deepest fears
and it limits it limits your heart
in the world because we we are all we've
heard this we're all
more than than the worst thing we've
ever done every one of us is
and we're all learning you know we're
all learning we're on this
this very steep learning curve that i
think has just gotten steeper
and the technology is forcing the
learning curve
because we've got to come to terms with
who we are
and what it means to be human to know
how to answer the questions of what
technology do we bring
do we bring into our lives you know
there are places where
the technology is it's already
changing what it means to be human there
are some societies i'll tell you japan
the japanese culture is a beautiful
example they've always been
uh very open to embracing technology and
they've always been on the forefront
and in some ways they're like the canary
in in the coal mine
because they have gone places now uh
that we can
we can look and say do we want to go
there one of
the examples of that and the scientific
papers that are
are describing this is that they are
replacing intimate human relationships
with digital relationships because
they're easier they're cleaner you don't
have to get
tied up in messy conversations you don't
have to get tied up
in arguments and disagreements so
they are relationships that are
happening online
uh including sexual relationships that
are happening online
well what's remember use it or lose it
one of the things they're finding in
japanese culture
is that women are losing their ability
to conceive
sperm counts are dropping in men and the
birth rate is now
dropped below the mortality rate people
are dying faster than
than babies are being born and it's not
a hundred percent because of the
technology but the technology
and the lifestyle have contributed to
these
to these things is that where we want to
go do we
and there is a movement i mean we could
have a conversation about this that is
called the transhuman movement
that firmly believes uh that
human carbon-based life and humans are
flawed that
uh sexuality is a distraction it's a
diversion that we don't need it and they
want to wean us from that so that we're
more efficient beings
and this is where a lot of this
technology is is going in
and wean us away they believe that
emotion
is our flaw and so as we become
less emotional beings we become more
efficient and better able to solve
problems
that's their their thinking i'm pushing
back strongly on that
it is that's the power of human emotion
that gives us the ability to
self-regulate
regenerate rejuvenate our biology in a
way that no other form of life
can so that we we awaken this soft
technology and hopefully
like i said have a lot of fun doing it